bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je poursuis
la vidéo précédente dans laquelle on
parlait de l'organisation du monde
scientifique et du fait que les
chercheurs pluridisciplinaires pouvaient
être désavantagées dans leur carrière et
en particulier les bons chercheurs parce
que justement ils sont plus à même de
bouleverser le statu quo de leur
discipline je vous mets un lien vers la
vidéo si vous ne l'avez pas encore vu
aujourd'hui on va se concentrer sur les
sciences humaines et sociales et se
demander si on y trouve plus facilement
les approches interdisciplinaires à
première vue les SHS semblent plus
naturellement portés sur la
pluridisciplanarité parce que elle
partage toute le même but qui est de
comprendre comment fonctionne l'humain
en société et ça semble assez logique
qu'on ne pourra répondre pleinement à la
question qu'on croisant les différentes
approches en sociologiques historique
psychologique économique etc en plus
dans la façon même qu'on a d'enseigner
ces disciplines dans le secondaire on
fait déjà des regroupements on a par
exemple les cours d'Histoire-Géographie
qui regroupent deux matières et on a
bien sûr les cours de ses sciences
économique et sociales qui regroupe
l'économie la sociologie et la science
politique
pourtant est-ce qu'on a pour autant des
approches pluridisciplinaires au lycée
quand on regarde plus finement les
programmes c'est loin d'être le cas pour
ce qui est des programmes de ses il y a
bien quelques thèmes qui sont labellisés
regards croisés mais 83% des chapitres
sont bien disciplinaires donc soit on
économie soit en sociologie dans le cas
de l'histoire-géographie je m'y connais
un peu moins bien mais il me semble bien
qu'on a d'un côté le cours de biographie
et de l'autre le cours d'histoire et de
toute façon au baccalauréat on avait
bien deux sous épreuves distinctes à
l'époque évidemment où on passait le bac
d'histoire-géo d'ailleurs a bien y
réfléchir ses disciplines multiples au
collège et au lycée sont presque des
bizarrés quand on regarde l'organisation
dans l'enseignement supérieur de fait il
n'existe pas de Master de ses ou de
Master d'histoire-géo en général les
professeurs de SES sont soit des
économistes qui se mettent à niveau en
socio soit des sociologues qui se
mettent à niveau en écho et c'est la
même chose pour les profs d'histoire-géo
qui ont bien souvent une discipline de
prédilection et d'ailleurs parfois ça se
sent un petit peu quand tu finis le
programme d'histoire au mois de mars
c'est qu'après il reste plus que deux
mois pour faire toute la géo mais je
suis à fond avec toi mais juste
promets-moi qu'on parle pas de
géographie je te jure car j'ai horreur
de ça moi aussi je déteste colorier les
océans c'est une punition les océans et
n'oubliez pas
bon du coup on n'est pas vraiment incité
à avoir des approches
pluridisciplinaires au collège et au
lycée mais qu'en est-il dans la
recherche en train de se faire est-ce
que les chercheurs se parlent entre les
différentes disciplines alors
heureusement oui les connaissances et le
circule pour parler de ce que je connais
la sociologie la façon de procéder est
bien plus souvent thématique que
disciplinaire en gros un sociologue qui
s'intéresse à une question il va en
général lire tout ce qui se dit sur le
sujet dans les différentes disciplines
il n'est d'ailleurs pas rare que des
chercheurs appartenant à des disciples
différentes collaborent pour mêler leurs
approches tenez par exemple en ce moment
je suis en train de lire au commencement
était des deux David le regretter David
griber qui est anthropologue et David
wengro qui est archéologue et c'est
d'ailleurs l'un des meilleurs livres que
j'ai commencé cette année je vous en
reparlerai peut-être dans une prochaine
vidéo
cela dit s'il y a effectivement des
collaborations l'organisation même de la
vie scientifique a quand même tendance à
pousser à un certain repli disciplinaire
ne serait-ce que parce que les
chercheurs appartiennent à des
départements différents au sein des
facultés on n'est pas toujours au
courant des recherches qui se font dans
le bureau d'à côté du coup que dire de
ce qui se passe deux états en dessous ou
de bâtiments plus loin et c'est vrai que
quand on regarde dans le détail sur
quelles études ça pue les chercheurs
dans leurs articles bah on voit qu'ils
ont assez rarement tendance à aller
chercher ailleurs que leur propre
discipline mais justement allons
regarder ça de plus près
[Musique]
une analyse a été faite entre 2000 et
2009 sur le réseau de citations des
trois grandes revues américaines que
sont l'American économique review
l'American politique
pour retracer d'où viennent les études
citées dans ses revues on a regardé la
fréquence de citation dans les 25 plus
grandes revues économie les 25 plus
grandes revues de sciences politiques et
les 25 plus grande revue de sociologie
si on regarde on a donc en ligne les
trois revues américaines étudiés et en
colonnes les 25 plus grandes revues de
chaque discipline si je vous affiche les
résultats on voit de façon assez peu
surprenante que chaque discipline a
tendance à s'auto-référencer c'est
particulièrement visible pour l'économie
parce que 40% des citations qu'on
retrouve dans l'American économique
review viennent toutes de ces mêmes 25
revues d'économies alors que dans les
autres disciplines les sources de
citations sont quand même un peu plus
diversifiées mais le plus flagrant c'est
si on regarde les citations
interdisciplinaires si on prend
l'exemple de l'économie et de la
sociologie on voit que les sociologues
cite assez peu les économistes c'est
2,3% de leur citation qui viennent des
revues d'économie mais reste bien
supérieur à la situation inverse parce
que seulement
0,3% des articles cités dans l’american
économique review viennent de la
sociologie ou du moins de ses 25 grandes
revues sociologiques donc ce qu'on voit
ici c'est que les sociologues cite les
économistes 7,6 fois plus souvent que
les économistes ne cite les sociologues
bon évidemment la mesure n'est pas sans
défaut parce que on pourrait imaginer
par exemple que les sociologues qui
citent des économistes bah ils vont
peut-être aller chercher dans d'autres
revues que les 25 premières mais ça
reste quand même une indication
intéressante ce qu'on peut conclure de
ce réseau de citations c'est que la
proche pluridisciplinaire en SAS ça
n'est pas très développée et c'est
encore plus vrai pour les économistes
qui ne semblent carrément pas disposés à
citer les autres disciplines ou vraiment
dans des proportions très très faibles
mais ça pour le coup c'est pas quelque
chose de particulièrement étonnant c'est
même quelque chose que les économistes
avouent directement quand on leur pose
la question de but en blanc de fait on a
posé la question aux chercheurs est-ce
que vous pensez que en général les
connaissances interdisciplinaires sont
meilleures que les connaissances
obtenues par une seule discipline et
bien 57% des économistes donc bien plus
de la moitié répondent directement non
non moi ce que je fais c'est cool mais
les autres ils peuvent aller se faire
cuire le cul avec la méthode de Babou là
non mais attendez entretiens
biographiques qu'est-ce que tu veux
qu'on fasse avec ça commence par
m'évaluer l'impact d'une politique
monétaire avec un modèle d'équilibre
général la dynamique soccer statique et
puis après on reparle bon tout ça ça
nous permet de voir qu'au sein des SHS
l'économie semble avoir une place toute
particulière c'est notamment ce que
l'économiste yanalgan et les sociologues
Marion Fourcade et Étienne au lion ont
étudié en 2015 dans un article intitulé
la supériorité des économistes publiés
dans le Journal of économique
perspective et c'est notamment de cet
article que viennent les données que
j'utilise depuis tout à l'heure
[Musique]
le premier constat à faire c'est que la
science économique jouit d'un plus grand
prestige que les autres sciences
sociales c'est vrai aussi bien dans
l'espace public que dans le son
académique par exemple il existe un prix
Nobel d'économie alors que il y a pas de
prix Nobel de sociologie de psychologie
ou d'anthropologie oui je sais le prix
Nobel d'économie c'est pas un vrai prix
Nobel il a été créé seulement en 69 par
la Banque de Suède et non pas par la
vraie Fondation Nobel mais bon en termes
de gratification symbolique ça change
rien parce que personne fait vraiment la
différence les prix Nobel jouissent d'un
grand prestige ils sont reçus dans les
médias et où les écoute même quand ils
s'expriment sur des sujets qui n'ont
rien à voir avec leur domaine
d'expertise mais outre les prix Nobel on
peut aussi voir que les économies sont
bien plus souvent écoutés par les
personnalités politiques ils peuvent
aussi accéder à des positions de
prestige comme conseiller économique de
ministres ont carrément gouverneur à la
banque centrale bah tiens justement on
vient juste de donner le prix Nobel
d'économie 2022 à Bender Nancy qui était
directeur de la fête de 2006 à 2014 et
pour les moldus la Fed c'est la banque
centrale américaine
on peut aussi remarquer que les
carrières en économie sont en général
bien plus rémunérés que dans les autres
sciences sociales regardez si on observe
les rémunérations moyennes entre 1999 et
2012 aux États-Unis on voit que le
salaire médian en économie tourne autour
de 90 000 dollars par an alors que si on
regarde les sociologues ils sont plutôt
aux alentours de 65000 dollars et ça
tombe à 60 000 dollars pour les
chercheurs en littérature anglaise donc
on a quand même un écart de 28% entre
l'économie et la sociologie et si on
regarde pour chaque discipline les 10%
les mieux rémunérés donc ce qu'on
appelle le desils supérieur on est après
de 160000 dollars par an pour les
économistes contre 115000 dollars pour
les sociologues en fait ce qu'on voit
c'est que les rémunérations des
économies sont très proches de celles de
la recherche en ingénierie alors que les
sociologues eux sont davantage payés
comme les chercheurs en littérature
moralité si vous hésitez entre plusieurs
disciplines du SHF et que ce qui vous
intéresse c'est la grosse Tunas
clairement il y a des choix plus
stratégiques que d'autres du moins c'est
le cas aux États-Unis je serai assez
intéressé pour voir le même genre
d'exercice sur des données françaises
bon du coup si on résume la situation on
a déjà assez petites stations entre les
différentes disciplines il y a en plus
une sorte d'hégémonie des sciences
économiques à la fois en termes de
rémunération matérielle symbolique mais
également politique je sais j'ai changé
de lunettes entre deux plans mais c'est
juste que j'avais mis les grosses
lunettes pour faire le caméo de
l'économiste et puis j'ai oublié de les
recharger tout à l'heure mais on s'en
fout en fait mais le problème ne
s'arrête en fait pas là parce que si on
regarde de plus près les sciences
économiques ou plutôt devrais-je dire la
science économique on va s'apercevoir
qu'il y a en fait extrêmement peu de
diversité à l'intérieur même de la
discipline et c'est ce qu'on va voir
maintenant
[Musique]
beaucoup moins cité et accède moins
facilement à des postes de prestige que
les économistes hétérodoxes qui adhèrent
au modèle dominant en particulier les
auteurs de l'article qu'on étudie
aujourd'hui montrent que les économistes
sont organisés de manière extrêmement
hiérarchiques et qu'il semble tous
partagés une même échelle du prestige
qui organise et structure leur
recrutement académique en gros là où en
sociologie on va avoir des écoles et des
tendances différentes en économie les
personnes qui sont à la tête des
départements universitaires ou des
grandes revues ils appartiennent tous au
courant mainstream et du coup ça
influence toute la chaîne de production
du savoir cette convergence elle se voit
notamment quand on regarde la
composition des associations de
chercheurs si on compare l'Association
Américaine d'économies avec
l'Association américaine de sociologie
et l'Association américaine de sciences
politiques on voit que la concentration
elle est particulièrement forte en
économie avec des membres qui viennent
dans tout petit nombre d'universités
très prestigieuses c'est ce que montre
ce graphique ou si on regarde d'où
viennent les membres exécutifs de
l'Association américaine des économistes
la EA et bien on en retrouve 72% qui
viennent des départements d'économie les
plus prestigieux et carrément aucun ne
provient de départements qui ne serait
pas au moins dans le top 20 alors que la
situation est presque inversée pour les
associations de sciences politiques et
de sociologie où le recrutement est
beaucoup plus diversifié venant même à
plus d'un tiers de départements côtés ce
qu'on voit c'est qu'on économie le
courant dominant devient de plus en plus
hégémonique au point qu'il devient
presque impossible de le discuter et de
le contredire dans les canaux normaux du
monde scientifique je vous donne un
exemple qui vient d'un autre article
mais qui illustre parfaitement ce
phénomène et qui montre que la science
économique d'aujourd'hui est beaucoup
moins lieu de débats que par le passé on
peut voir ça quand on regarde dans les
revues la proportion d'articles publiés
qui sont une réponse une critique ou un
commentaire à un autre article publié
précédemment comme on le voit sur ce
graphique qui s'appuie sur les 5 grandes
revues économiques américaines on avait
dans les années 70 presque 20% des
articles publiés qui étaient une réponse
ou en commentaire à un autre article
alors que ce n'est plus que 2% des
articles publiés aujourd'hui
entre parenthèses ce graphique je trouve
assez fou parce que je trouve qu'il
donne à voir complètement le changement
de paradigme dans la pensée économique
avec un foisonnement de discussions et
de débats après la guerre et pendant les
Trente Glorieuses qui ont fait la part
belle aux idées keynésiennes sur le plan
scientifique et politique puis le
tournant de la rigueur des années 1980
et une science économique qui se range
au nouveau paradigme néolibéral hérité
notamment du courant monétariste de
Milton Friedman évidemment je simplifie
à mort mais quand même ça me semble pas
complètement à côté de la plaque en
d'autres termes ça veut dire que le
débat a complètement déserté les revues
d'économie prestigieuses ça veut pas
dire qu'ils ont complètement disparu ils
existent a priori toujours dans d'autres
revues mais le fait qu'il n'apparaissent
plus dans les cinq grandes revues montre
la convergence de courant et de méthode
qui s'est opérée dans la science
économique précise qu'on s'appuie ici
sur des données américaines mais sachez
que c'est exactement la même chose en
France pour la France on peut prendre
l'exemple de Philippe avion sans
économiste très reconnue il a enseigné à
Harvard et à la London School of
Economics et depuis 2015 il est
carrément le professeur d'économie au
Collège de France bonjour monsieur et
ben Philippe à Lyon s'inscrit
complètement dans le modèle de
l'économie dominante alors lui plus
précisément il appartient à ce qu'on
appelle le courant Neo schumpeterien
c'est à dire qu'il est persuadé que
l'innovation va nous sauver de tout
quand on l'écoute parler d'écologie
c'est solution miracle elle tourne
souvent autour d'un meilleur système
d'incitation et de protection des
brevets pour encourager l'innovation
vertes parce qu'on parle toujours des
modèles alternatifs moi je vais vous
dire la vérité je crois beaucoup je vais
vous dire je pense qu'on n'a pas fait
mieux que l'économie de marché réguler
voilà donc ça c'était son intervention
aux journées de l'économie de Lyon sur
la table ronde peut-on sauver le climat
par l'innovation et autant vous dire
qu'il avait une réponse beaucoup plus
optimiste que les autres personnes
autour de la table alors moi j'ai
répondu en dans un premier temps à la
question est-ce que l'innovation va
sauver le climat en disant la réponse
est non pour ma part à la question qui
est posée est-ce que l'innovation peut
sauver le climat je vais dire non alors
évidemment l'idée n'est pas non plus de
caricaturer sa pensée le mec est quand
même hyper intéressant et je vous invite
d'ailleurs à consulter ses cours au
Collège de France qui sont en libre
accès il y tient la chair économie des
institutions de l'innovation et de la
croissance et il y a des dizaines
d'heures de conférences disponibles mais
même s'il est super intéressant sur ce
thème de prédilection il reste quand
même attaché à une vision de l'économie
à Samed stream et ça ne l'empêche pas de
manquer un petit peu de conviction sur
certains sujets comme quand il défend
les ordonnances travail d'Emmanuel
Macron en mettant en avant que plus de
flexibilité du marché du travail
encourageant Bosch et plus précisément
les contrats longs les contrats longs
mais ça vous nous le dites au doigt
mouillés
il y a eu des études qui voilà il y a
des études j'ai pas je peux pas vous
dire voilà telle étude mais enfin je
sais que c'est voilà c'est c'est prouvé
c'est établi mais il pense qu'il y a eu
des études heureusement qu'il est là me
voilà convaincu maintenant bref tout ça
pour vous dire que Philippe haguillon
donc il est professeur au Collège de
France il est aussi conseillé économique
d'Emmanuel Macron et c'est également lui
qui a piloté l'écriture des programmes
de sciences économiques et sociales au
lycée donc ça ça nous montre en quoi une
seule personne à un poste très
prestigieux va avoir une influence
considérable à la fois sur la politique
économique mais aussi sur l'enseignement
de l'économie dans le supérieur et dans
le secondaire et ça c'est pas rien parce
que ça donne une certaine vision de
l'économie à toute une génération de
lycéens
alors là initialement je faisais une
parenthèse sur le programme d'économie
au lycée mais ça m'a rajouté encore 10
minutes de vidéo du coup je l'ai viré
pour faire plus court mais dites-moi
quand même dans les commentaires si
c'est quelque chose qui vous
intéresserait pour une vidéo hors-série
ou un truc comme ça
[Musique]
quand il est sorti le fameux article de
Lyon Fourcade et algants a suscité
quelques réactions chez les économistes
notamment parce qu'il les accusait assez
directement d'être arrogant avec un gros
esprit de chapelle quelques réactions
sont savoureuses comme celles de Noah
Smith de l'Université de Michigan qui
nous explique par exemple que si les
économies sont mieux payés avec les
sociologues c'est tout simplement parce
que le marché reconnaît leur supériorité
CQFD merci Madame gloire à la main
invisible des marchés cela dit on a
aussi eu une réaction du prix Nobel
d'économie Paul kruckman c'est un
chercheur assez intéressant un peu plus
ouvert que la plupart des économistes et
orthodoxes et je vous invite d'ailleurs
vraiment à lire son livre lutter contre
les zombies alors j'ai été moi aussi
très déçu ça parle pas du tout de zombie
ça parle plutôt d'un certain nombre de
mythes économiques qui sont entretenus
dans la discipline uniquement pour des
fins politiques en plus ça se lit très
bien parce que c'est une compilation
d'articles qu'il a écrit dans le monde
et au sujet de l'article dont on parle
aujourd'hui il nous dit que les grands
économistes sont souvent
intellectuellement arrogant parce qu'ils
vivent dans un milieu très hiérarchisé
où les différences de prestige sont
fortes où tout le monde s'accorde sur ce
qui constitue un travail de qualité et
sur les auteurs de ce travail et où
atteindre le sommet s'accompagne de
grandes récompenses je trouve ça assez
édifiant et ça montre assez bien en quoi
il est nécessaire d'analyser les
conditions de production des
connaissances scientifiques et oui parce
que même si la science c'est avant tout
la recherche de la vérité les
scientifiques sont eux-mêmes des
personnes qui sont insérées dans un
espace social compétitif avancer dans
une carrière scientifique ce n'est donc
pas uniquement avancé sur le chemin de
la vérité mais c'est aussi faire face à
des contraintes être incités à publier
le plus possible et s'insérer dans un
courant de pensée si on espère voir sa
carrière avancée et c'est d'autant plus
vrai dans les disciplines très
hiérarchisées en fait ce qu'on est en
train de faire là c'est typiquement une
analyse en terme de champ dans la
sociologie de Pierre Bourdieu on
explique le comportement des économistes
par le fait qu'ils évoluent dans un
champ particulier qui est à la fois très
hiérarchique et très unifiée et si vous
voulez en savoir plus sur la sociologie
pour Dieu allez voir la vidéo que j'ai
fait au début de l'année du coup on peut
dire que oui les économies sont bien
arrogants même si maintenant on peut
expliquer pourquoi d'ailleurs les
économistes eux-mêmes ne remettent
jamais vraiment en question ce point là
même pour Noël Smith les économistes
sont effectivement arrogants mais pour
lui c'est normal parce qu'ils ont été
adoublés par le marché donc ils ont tout
lieu de l'être pour reprendre les mots
de Baptiste coolmont et de Pierre Merley
c'est un peu comme si les économistes
nous disaient vous proposez des drôles
d'explications mais oui nous sommes
arrogants je vous parle de coolmont et
merkley parce que l'idée de cet épisode
n'est venu en lisant leur petit livre
qui s'appelle pourquoi les top models ne
sourient pas chroniques sociologique
c'est une compilation d'articles qu'ils
ont écrit pour le monde ça se lit très
facilement et je vous mettrai dans la
description un lien vers l'article
Astérix chez les économistes qui aborde
le sujet de cette vidéo
[Musique]
bon du coup on vient de voir que c'est
quand même assez difficile d'organiser
de la pluridisciplinarité au sein des
sciences sociales si une majorité de
chercheurs estime pourtant qu'elle est
bénéfique on voit qu'une toute petite
minorité d'articles cité dans une étude
appartiennent à une autre discipline et
on voit que ce phénomène il est encore
plus grand pour les disciplines très
hiérarchiques comme l'économie ou non
seulement on va pas chercher des travaux
dans d'autres disciplines mais où en
plus les revues et les postes
prestigieux semblent tous réserver au
courant dominant de la discipline en
laissant de côté tous les courants
étaient rodoxes à titre personnel je
pense que vous avez compris que je suis
plutôt en faveur de la
pluridiscipénalité j'estime que les
sciences humaines fonctionnent mieux
quand elles travaillent ensemble et pour
moi c'est un problème que l'économie
essaye de se rapprocher des standards
des sciences de la nature parce que
justement à force de faire des modèles
mathématiques compliqués on en vient à
oublier qu'on travaille en fait sur des
sociétés humaines et que il n'existe pas
de loi économiques en dehors des
institutions sociales d'ailleurs si
cette question des courants économiques
vous intéresse vous donne rendez-vous le
mercredi 16 novembre 2022 au gecko
journée d'économie de Lyon où il y aura
une table ronde sur le pluralisme dans
l'enseignement de l'économie bon alors
évidemment ma vidéo sort plus tard que
je ne l'avais prévu donc la Table Ronde
des gecko a déjà eu lieu mais elle est
disponible intégralement en replay et je
vous invite à aller la consulter c'était
vraiment super intéressant le
recrutement des professeurs d'économie
qui n'a jamais été aussi
fait avant estimé qu'il représentait
quatre pour cent je dis bien 4% de
l'ensemble des recrutements des
professeurs depuis 2017-2018 et disons
que sur la période
2005-2018 c'était environ 12 à 13% donc
c'était trois fois plus même si c'était
évidemment déjà très faible et il me
semble que c'est une question d'intérêt
général aussi qui dépasse amplement le
corporatisme qui engage la démocratie de
savoir si dans nos sociétés et dans
l'académisme on accepte ou pas la
confrontation entre différentes écoles
de pensée avec des positions sur
l'anthropologie humaine sur le rapport
politique et voilà cet épisode des
coulisses de la recherche est maintenant
terminée dites moi en commentaire si ce
troisième épisode vous a plu c'est la
première fois que je parle d'économie
sur la chaîne alors que c'est aussi
quelque chose qui me passionne donc
dites moi si dans l'absolu c'est quelque
chose qui peut vous intéresser sachant
que c'est vrai qu'en termes de chaîne
économique on est déjà plutôt gâté sur
Youtube ça je le sais si comme moi vous
aimez l'approche pluridisciplinaire la
relation sociale je vous encourage à
jeter un oeil vers une revue super
géniale qui s'appelle regard croisé sur
l'économie c'est une revue plus réaliste
qui se propose justement de faire passer
des savoirs savants en étant au plus
près de la recherche en train de se
faire et en mêlant différents approches
dans le même sujet ils ont une page
Facebook qui publie tous les mercredis
des articles en accès libre et en
général si en lien avec l'actualité donc
c'est super intéressant et si a priori
ça vous intéresse mais que la lecture
quand même c'est compliqué et ben sachez
que la revue vient de se lancer sous
forme de podcast ça s'appelle voix
croisée sur l'économie et le premier
épisode sur les JO de Paris 2024 est
disponible depuis le 9 octobre donc
foncez écoutez ça mais avant de partir
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner de mettre
un pouce vers le haut et de partager la
vidéo si elle vous a plu c'est super
important de partager moi je m'aperçois
que finalement je vous ai donné quand
même pas mal de recommandations de
lecture aujourd'hui donc ça vous tiendra
occupé jusqu'à la prochaine fois je vous
dis à très vite pour de nouvelles
aventures des gros bisous Ciao
[Musique]